ian's good morning how are you hi Dan
how are you I'm doing okay I had a
couple of questions about Bella check
going into this game we always talk
about Bella check takes away your best
weapon first of all and doing your book
with Bella check you know understanding
how he does this does he look at Patrick
mahomes is Kansas City's best weapon or
Tyreke he'll I think that's that's a
very good question he might look at
he'll really more as the weapon to try
to neutralize it's hard to completely
neutralize a quarterback as you know and
if you go back to that first Super Bowl
victory over the Rams
it was Marshall Faulk that he focused on
it was not Kurt Warner now he wanted to
hit Warner of course as often as his
front could but in fact he had a
conversation with Chris Berman before
that game where Berman asked him
off-camera how are you gonna win this
game and Belichick told him Marshall
Faulk will not beat us on Sunday and and
he didn't they made sure that they
mauled him at every opportunity wouldn't
let him get out of the backfield force
the officials to call fouls as often as
possible until they decided they didn't
want to be the story in that game so in
Kurt Warner thought that was the
philosophy foul foul foul and at some
point the referees are going to stop
throwing the flag and it was an
interesting approach but I could see
this being more of a hill game plan I do
think he wants to keep Mahone in the
pocket because when he's outside the
pocket creating plays that's when he's
most dangerous you wrote in the last
couple of pages of your book about
Belichick losing that locker room
because we still haven't received a full
explanation on the benching of Malcom
Butler in the Super Bowl has he has he
won that locker room back and if so how
I think so Dan I think just by being
himself by being the greatest coach and
the one thing about beyond the the
Butler benching and the Super Bowl which
really angered the the vast majority of
that roster including Tom Brady was the
relationship with Brady had really
fractured I think it's amazing it took
18 years for that to happen given just
these immense pressure those two are
under on a day-to-day basis working in
close
for 18 years to be the greatest ever at
what they do but it did happen and I
think that relationship needed to
survive that one tumultuous moment in
time and it did and now they're back to
being a transactional very successful
partnership I think they're in a pretty
good working place and that's a big part
of it but Tom Brady always knew that
Belichick was the best coach in the
league and probably the best coach of
all time it was just that after what
happened last year the way it happened
and then the the Butler benching was
sort of the final straw and I think they
just needed time to heal they got that
time and now they're back in a good
place and outside of the one gap in in
Miami
putting Gronk on the field at the end of
that game with the surreal lateral play
against the Dolphins
I think Belichick actually had one of
his better years coaching this football
team and I was gonna bring that up like
how does Belichick in good faith good
conscience put Gronk out there as his
safety and that cost New England the
number one seed the title game would be
in Foxborough this weekend all I would
say is he's human he makes mistakes and
even the greatest ever they sometimes
make mistakes and I think that was a big
one and there's no reasonable
explanation when there was no way
Tannehill was going to be able to reach
the end zone or even really come close
to have Gronk on the field it was just a
mistake a human mistake that the best
coach in the league made and frankly
going into this game Sunday then maybe
he feels deep down in a place he would
never admit exists for public
consumption
he's got to find a way to make up for
that because otherwise that game would
be in Foxborough the Patriots would
probably be the favorite to win the game
I still think they have a good chance if
not a very good chance to to win at
Arrowhead but yeah that was damaging it
was just he's human he made a mistake
and there's no reasonable explanation
for it who cares more about their legacy
mellow checkered Brady I think deep down
they both care deeply about it I think
that Brady and Belichick are really I
think when they say they don't care
about stats
only care about winnings they really
actually mean it I don't know if
everybody really means it when they say
it but I think those two do and I think
that's how they're they're driven to go
back to the bell chick really I think
there are wounds there from not being
made the the Giants head coats that was
a job he always wanted it's a job he
deserved he didn't get at the GM at the
time George Young just despised him and
that's one of the main reasons why he
didn't get that job and the failures in
Cleveland the the criticism I think has
really driven him across his career in
New England and Brady of course the chip
on his shoulder for from being the 199th
pick in the draft boy car really coached
him in an unforgiving way just like
Belichick and and that's part the reason
why the relationship with Belichick
really unraveled last year is it wasn't
just 18 straight years of unrelenting
coaching from Belichick it was 23 when
you include the five with Lloyd Carr and
I think it wore Brady to the nub and and
that's why it happened the way it did
but I think where he was drafted has
really driven him over the years to be
the greatest ever at what he does
you see and O'Connor the best-selling
book is Belichick that's online wherever
books are sold what's the one story you
get asked about the most from the book I
think people want to ask about really
the way Bill is away from the office and
I have a lot of human humanizing
anecdotes in the book about the fact
that it's a Jekyll and Hyde act if you
will and I think it's strategic the way
he is in his news conferences and the
way America sees him and his whole
approach when he's at the offices 24/7
I'm only going to do what I think helps
us win football games and if that means
putting on that act in his news
conferences where he believes we're in
the business of collecting information
never sharing it therefore when I'm
asked questions I'm going to give as
little information as possible and
that's just the way it's going to be I
think it's strategic when he's away from
the office talking to friends and
associates he's an entirely different
human being and he can be charming and
engaging and kind and warm and all those
things and I have those anecdotes in the
book I think people around the country
really wanted to see if that site
actually exists
even though it's really at odds with the
public persona that he carries on on a
daily basis if the Patriots would win
the Superbowl the word retirement would
probably come up for a couple of players
who do you think would be labeled with
that and follow through with retirement
well I think Gronk especially I mean
half the time he looks like a mummy out
there on the field as it is and if he
can contribute to a championship team
this year he can go start his career in
pro wrestling in Hollywood and or be the
next Schwarzenegger or whatever he wants
to do I think physically he's so beat to
hell right now that that would be the
most logical prominent player on the
Patriots side to retire Tom Brady before
the Super Bowl last year dan he told a
friend of his who told me that hey
winning three out of four a second time
would be a great way to go out now
publicly Brady has said age 45 I think
he's going to play some more I had a
conversation with him in the spring of
17 on the phone where we were talking
about him playing at age 46 and 47 never
mind 45 so even if he wins it I think
he's going to come back and play but I
think Gronk is the one who walks away
see I thought for sure that if Brady won
last year that was it he was done I
think I think Gisele was put enough
public pressure on him that it feels
like when he goes home he hears that too
that we have young kids I want you to be
around I see what happens with these
other players I don't want you to you
know fall victim to that so I thought
for sure I'd be on the podium handing
the trophy to him and I would have been
asking him about retirement here's the
thing Dan and you might be right but he
compelled the franchise to trade his
much younger successor Garoppolo right
how do you then after saying publicly
you're gonna play to your at least 45
and you've now inspired the franchise to
trade her successor then walk away after
one or two years at age 40 41 I just
don't think he can do that okay but how
involved was he with Garoppolo because
it's one of my favorite topics it just
feels like he orchestrated that whether
he went above Belichick went to craft
and said look
I'll play but you got to get rid of him
fill us in on that I don't think he
demanded the trade of Garoppolo I
definitely believe in talking to sources
and talking to the 350 people for this
book and that he had conversations with
craft about his security he was very
worried about Belichick moving away from
him after the season and going with
Garoppolo and that's bills history
that's what he does Tom Brady was
worried about Garoppolo from the moment
he was drafted in 2014 he was worried
about Garoppolo after his last game in
Kansas City early in that 2014 season so
that has been a very big part of his run
over these last five seasons or four
seasons anyway with Garoppolo there the
fear that he would lose his job and he's
always been like that he was like that
at Michigan with drew Henson he probably
had more caused the worry back at
Michigan with drew Henson but I do think
he had conversations with his owner who
he has a great warm relationship with
about securing his future and then from
that bill walks away and makes the move
I don't think Tom Brady ever said you
have to trade Jimmy Garoppolo did you
find out if Belichick wrote read the
book no I haven't heard directly from
him I've heard some people around him
my belief is he devotes so much time and
energy to the season he didn't have time
to read the whole thing
III know people around him read it and
briefed him on it I have not heard
directly from him but I did send him a
note when I found the book and I just
hoped in the note I expressed this that
he just saw it as a fair and exhaustive
examination of his career is in his life
you know knowing Belichick he probably
gave an assignment to somebody I need a
book report on this thing exactly and
but maybe someday we'll have a
conversation about it he did not
cooperate of course for the book but I
just hope he sees it for what it was
intended to be and that was fair
Ian thank you we appreciate your time
thank you Dan
ESPN senior writer author of the New
York Times bestseller
Belichick Ian O'Connor for more Dan
Patrick show to the
it's channel 239 on DirecTV or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]